Hey,
what's going on it's Bill Burr.
It's time for the Thursday afternoon.
Just before Friday.
Monday morning podcast.
And Ah,
just checking in on you.
I'm just checking in on you to see how your work weeks ago and
you know,
fucking weird one this year.
It's 4th of July on a Wednesday.
You know,
if it's on the Tuesday,
maybe your boss gives you the Monday off,
right?
You got a three day fucking week after a four day weekend.
It's beautiful.
You know,
it's on Thursday.
Maybe you don't have to come in Friday.
There's your four day fucking weekend.
Not this year.
Ah,
no.
All fucking powdered wig itself came in on a Wednesday.
Fucked everybody Monday.
Tuesday.
Right?
Everybody fucks off for Wednesday.
Now you gotta come back Thursday,
Friday.
It's cool to get the day off,
but you didn't get the consecutive days off,
you know?
Do you know he got fucked up the night of July 3rd,
right?
And yesterday.
What'd you do?
You eat a bunch of fucking burgers?
Is that what you did?
Uh,
I am finally on the other side of this.
God damn cold.
I caught one of these posts,
global warming,
Mother Nature is going to start getting rid of us called this fucking thing.
It came on slow,
you know,
and then it just started picking up speed and it just grabbed me by the fucking
throat and just choke,
slammed me.
Uh,
yeah.
So I'm finally,
finally on the other side of it though.
He wouldn't know what to hear me right now,
but I am,
um,
I want to thank all you guys for your postcards and your well wishes
meant a lot to me.
You know,
when I was sitting there laying there in the hospital bed,
uh,
I actually was the first guy who ever went to the hospital for a common cold in
the San Fernando Fernando Valley area.
They made a plaque for me and everything.
I went in there and the doctor was just like looking at my chart.
They find looked up,
he's like,
so you got the sniffles?
And I was like,
yeah.
It's like,
you know,
I have a whole emergency room full of people that got stabbed and shot.
And I was like,
yeah,
I know.
But like one of my nostrils is like really clogged up and I just can't like deal
man.
Um,
I tell you guys,
I saw that,
that documentary on Mark Ronson
that his name,
no,
not mark Ronson.
The fucking guy who played with David Bowie is Mark Ronson,
the guy,
Mick Ronson.
Mick Ronson is the one mark Ronson is this is your mother,
your father,
your sister,
whatever that fucking song is.
It's Jalyn by in eight and some peanut butter.
It's a fucking [inaudible].
Dabba do let me see your titties,
right?
Isn't that how that song went?
Uh,
Mick
play with David Bowie when he was Ziggy start us in the spiders and I'm fucking
incredible guitarist.
Credible musician,
a producer wrote songs,
you know,
learn how to write out all the music and all this shit.
And he got no fucking credit.
Got No fucking credit,
didn't get any money.
They fucked him.
I just,
the music business is the absolute worst.
I can't tell you how many fucking times I've seen that.
Okay.
You know,
the drummer and the Bass player on those first two Ozzie Solo albums,
like they just,
they just fuck those guys.
They just,
you know,
guys coming in and writing riffs and writing entire fucking songs,
but they're two,
they don't have a good lawyer.
Nobody tells them what's up.
They don't get the,
uh,
you know,
and then it's like sound by Ozzy Osborne and then did they get fucked out of
millions of dollars?
How do you do that to a kid?
It's just this reoccurring thing in the fucking music business is fucking guy
was writing all these riffs.
He was writing the string arrangements.
He was in the fucking studio with one of those conductor ones.
They didn't,
you didn't get any fucking credit.
It's fucking brutal.
Uh,
but what was amazing was watching the guy,
uh,
I saw him,
I was like,
Jesus Christ,
that guy looks like fucking Randy Rhoads same haircut,
same fucking Les Paul and all that.
I'm like,
wait,
Randy Rhodes came after Mick Ronson.
So then I just looked googled Randy Rhoads,
a Mick Ronson influence at a bunch of Shit,
came out saying that he was a fan of thought that was pretty cool,
you know,
and already had more of the classical guitar type of stuff in there.
But,
you know,
say,
uh,
let's see.
Yeah,
it's a good documentary.
I saw it on a plane though.
You know,
whenever you want to play at every,
everything's fucking good guys.
I look lady,
I fucking,
I'm still,
I'm coming out of this shit man.
You know,
I don't know what it feels like to be trapped in a mine.
Yeah,
I'll fuck.
Are there some kids right now trapped somewhere?
The news is just so brutal.
I just,
I wasn't ready to,
I just see like the headline.
I just go,
ah,
I just walk away.
I don't know how people just sit there watching other people's suffering.
It's one thing to say,
hey,
these kids are trapped in a mine right over there.
Grab a shovel,
come with me.
Then you can do something.
But they just know this sitting there and there's nothing you can fucking do
about it.
You know,
Kinda fucked.
Do a bunch of kids end up in a month?
Is that what happened?
They had a mine,
I had a fucking movie stuck on a giant lily pad or something like that in the
middle of the river.
I don't know.
I bet.
Uh,
you know,
I've been like fucking hallucinating all God damn week.
But,
uh,
one of the good things about being this sick as I haven't drank in like fucking
five days,
you know,
and uh,
I got some active work next week,
so whenever I got acting work,
I shut down all the fun,
you know.
Oh Billy,
no fund,
you know,
try to keep my face not fucking,
I'll fucking puffy and shit.
Um,
so anyways,
Oh God,
I got nothing.
Jesus Christ.
They got nothing.
But I gotta knock this up.
Hmm.
This is how funny I am when I'm fucking sick for five days.
I'm basically not funny at all.
Okay.
And I would appreciate it if you guys would just cut me a little bit of
fucking slack.
All right.
You know what I had,
I had a few,
uh,
I fucked up,
when I was uploading the Monday morning podcast when,
uh,
they can,
my,
the battery on my laptop died.
So 15 minutes in the middle got cut out.
So we had to edit it,
edit it together.
So there's some fucking people wrote in some questions that I'm going to re
answer them the best I can.
By the way on Instagram I found this account that I've been following
called don't be a Brad and it's basically a trashing like essentially a meathead
white guy,
frat boys.
MMM.
You know,
it's funny,
they kind of,
you know,
it's hilarious because you know,
there's a lot of truth to it.
But then also it's like you completely judging these people by their skin color
and nobody gives a fuck cause it's fucking white guys.
But a lot of them are just really good looking guys who are in frats and they're
getting a lot of pussy and your fucking annoyed by it because you're a nerd.
So you started this account.
Having said that,
it is funny,
like they literally have one of them yelling at about six.
Do you know what my dad does?
Yeah.
You know,
and everybody makes fun of these Frat kids.
It's not their fucking fault,
it's their parents.
It's like making fun of millennials.
It's like,
it's not,
it's the people who raised them that fucked them up.
But it's a very funny account
I'll be in.
A lot of it,
you know,
is just unathletic people making fun of people who are athletic.
Um,
and then there's also something to where,
you know,
there's a curse to be in fucking good looking.
You know,
I was reading this one time,
this article in rolling stone in this guy who was just like this heartthrob for
fucking 15 years was now like in his sixties and he was doing this fucking,
this interview and they were talking to him and he was reflecting on what kind
of a person he was back in his twenties in his thirties he said,
well,
you know,
I was,
he was basically saying he was a really good looking guy.
He was on a TV show and in movies and he had a big Dick.
So he only had to develop so much as a human being.
Yeah,
it was really fascinating.
So then when he got old,
he wasn't as good looking.
He was creepy to younger women and shit.
He actually had to finish developing all development as a human that he never
had to do before because all he did was just show up in all the women.
Faith did that.
He pulled out his giant Dick,
you know,
or he fucking went to town.
It was dealt with.
Daddy went back down to the movie set and made another hit movie.
It was very,
very interesting.
So I actually was thinking of that.
What I was looking at that don't be a Brad.
Okay.
Uh,
Instagram account.
Well,
it's like this isn't these kids 100% their fault.
Like if your kid is walking around and acting like an asshole and then go and do
you know what my dad does for a living?
Uh,
you spoiled the shit out of that kid.
That's your fucking fault.
That,
I mean that's complete failure as a dad.
If your kids out there being a fucking,
you know,
Mauldin off to some bouncer that could fucking twist them up like a pretzel and
then screaming like,
my dad's going to come down here.
Oh my God.
I just be like son,
son.
Fight your own battles.
Like what are you doing?
I'm going to come down here and do what?
Sue Him cause you're a fucking asshole.
I don't want to see you get a concussion but he should have slapped the shit out
of you.
All right.
Republican?
Yes.
Douche question mark.
Uh,
hey bill,
I'm a fan of your comedy.
I'm still a fan of you,
but artistically you're starting to sound like a red pill.
Republican Douche bag.
You know,
isn't it just classically classical like way that the politics is discussed now?
like his whole,
the thing is called Republican douchey question mark.
I like,
I don't understand these people where if,
if you're a republican that automatically you're a Douche.
If you're a democrat you're automatically a Douche.
You know what I mean?
You know?
You know what I'm saying?
Like,
like,
you don't think anybody on either.
Like everybody on that side is just douche bags.
Um,
anyways,
he goes,
no offense,
you're always going on about how Hillary is evil while our country is going down
the shitter.
And she would've saved us from a lot of these headaches.
All right,
well that's pretty vague.
Our country has been going down the shitter for a long time,
sir.
I don't know what you're talking about when exactly,
wasn't it going down the shitter?
You know,
I was speaking to that,
you know,
back in the,
uh,
of that fucking don't be a Brad.
One of the frat boys had Ronald Reagan tattooed on his calf.
Not a picture.
It just said Ronald Reagan.
That fucking was,
that's hilarious to me.
You know,
Ronald Reagan is like rich white people's Abraham Lincoln.
Like he set them free in a way by,
you know,
by,
deregulating everything.
So then these fucking robber barons could get back to what the fuck they wanted
to be doing.
Um,
oh look at that.
I just made fun of her,
sir.
Uh,
do I sound like a red pill?
Republican Douche bag will be this guy.
He's like literally speaking in soundbites like how fucking like how boring a
conversation,
what to discuss politics with this person.
Um,
anyways,
he say you say you don't like Trump Trump,
but you sound like a closet fan who's just too afraid to say you love him cause
you lose a part donut store.
Employee number two.
Thank you.
Missed a word in there buddy.
Um,
I'm not afraid to say that I like Trump.
If I like Trump,
I don't like him.
Yeah,
And
yeah,
his fucking wife.
The fact that she wore that jacket that said I don't really care to you.
When she was going to see those kids and then tried to say like,
oh that had to do with fake news like this,
such passive aggressive fucking pussies.
Yeah.
That had nothing to do with fake news.
Like you're telling me nobody at the White House.
This is about fake news.
Well a,
just to let you know if they are first lady,
people might think you're talking about the kids,
you might not want to wear that.
It was such like a fucking,
you know,
it's bad enough when a guy's that ignorant bought a woman,
does it?
She's actually had kids.
She knows what it's like to have a fucking kid and they sit there and have these
kids and fucking cages and she wears a jacket like that.
It's just,
and I was fucking,
they're not human.
So anyways.
Um,
yeah,
he said,
I can't tell if it's set.
Your fan base is all a bunch of moderate morons.
Yeah.
Who would rather be concern contrarians than pick the good guys are the bad
guys.
Why don't you just pick a side because clearly this is a good guy,
bad guy thing going on here.
Question Mark.
Uh,
that's probably one of the most ignorant,
condescending fucking,
yeah.
Emails I've ever gotten.
You didn't make one fucking point.
You just spoken big broad soundbites.
I get it.
You're a Democrat and you think everybody who's a Republican,
he's a Douche and the country's going down the shitter.
And if we picked a Democrat,
it wouldn't be going down the shitter.
And there are good guys and there are bad guys.
And the good guys are Democrats are the bad guys are Republicans.
Right?
Hey,
by the way,
did you see the house,
the Obama's just fucking bought,
you know,
how the fuck did they have the money to buy that fucking house?
Explain that to me.
You know,
every fucking one of them,
whether you wear a blue tie or a red tie,
they come out of the White House worth fucking,
you know,
tens of millions of dollars other than Bill Clinton because he stuck his cigar.
That woman's Pussy.
He had a lot of fucking legal bills.
Uh,
but even they give her the fucking Clinton set it up with Pete.
Hundreds of billions.
Well,
actually Bill Clinton said he came out of the White House in debt,
but he also said audit not have sex with that woman.
So he probably had fucking millions of dollars.
Uh,
I don't like any of them,
sir.
I don't,
uh,
I liked,
Bernie Sanders,
Bernie Sanders.
I liked,
I'm not saying he would've solved everything,
but uh,
God knows CIB.
He,
he got,
he got the majority of the vote and the Democrats said,
fuck that.
We're still giving the Dobbin the domination to Hillary.
And she was fine with that.
That had the fucking nerve to sit there and bitch about the fucking election.
Uh,
that last election was 2:00 AM at a bar,
sir.
There was no,
there was no wedding.
There was no winning.
That one.
Uh,
I mean,
Hillary literally said in 2008 to the bankers.
Don't worry.
I got you guys like out basically cover for you guys.
I mean,
you should be tried for fucking trees and when you do shit like that,
uh,
I don't see any difference between her or Trump.
I don't,
they're complete,
uh,
pieces of shit that are out for themselves who act like they're there for you.
And it's weird if they were a certain color fucking shirt
some half the country believes it.
Uh,
all right.
25 year old buying an old house.
All right.
Hey,
Billy doughboy from 25 years old,
just graduated with my masters and got a dream job.
Yeah,
a dream teaching job in Philly.
You're teaching in Philadelphia where you got your work cut out for you.
Fuck with you.
MMM.
Anyways,
I got my dream job teaching in Philadelphia.
Where the fuck did it just go?
I just lost everything here.
Oh,
belly.
All right.
Okay.
With how cheap the housing market is.
I figured it would be a smart decision to buy a house now rather than wait 10
years.
Uh,
I found a great old house in Philly.
It's in my price.
Wage should be price range,
move in ready and has all the details I love about old houses.
They accepted my offer and they closed at the end of the month.
That's exciting.
25 years old and you got a house dude,
you get your dream job,
you're crushing it.
I gotta do is pick the right lady and you're good.
You pick the wrong one and she'll take all of it from you.
But you won't see that Hashtag on Twitter.
Will Ya?
Uh,
after listening to your podcast for a couple of years,
I know that you have a love hate relationship with your old house.
Yes I do.
Is there any advice that you have for me,
for me as I move in and make my first real adult purchase?
Thanks for keeping me and many other teachers saying with your podcast.
Um,
all right,
well if you're going to buy an old houses,
uh,
Jesus,
I don't even know where to begin.
The first thing I would start with is the guts of the house.
Uh,
if he,
if he got the money,
if you can redo the electrical and the plumbing or find out to what extent it
has been redone because I had a bunch of cloth wiring and galvanized pipes in my
walls.
You don't want to fire and you don't want to get flooded.
So that's usually a big thing there.
Um,
yeah,
I say had a minor gas leak,
you might want to look for stuff like that.
Once you get to the guts
that I would deal with the,
as far as,
um,
you know,
there's gonna be a bunch of Shit,
I check out your roof.
That's another thing I would check for termites.
That's another thing.
MMM.
I actually have all like the skeleton keys for every door in the house that I
got them.
So they all work.
And then within two and a half,
three years of doing it,
the house settled some more.
And now most of the bolts don't line up with the thing.
And I just,
I just stopped fighting the house after a while.
It's just like,
all right,
I get it.
This house is almost a hundred years old and,
uh,
it's going to do what the fuck it wants to do.
So,
um,
I would just,
you know,
once you get the electrical,
the plumbing done,
that's like the biggest thing,
then you can slowly kind of fix up everything else.
But a,
and what I tried to do is,
um,
you know,
as I upgrade,
like,
you know,
you upgrade the electrical and the plumbing,
nobody's going to see that.
So,
you know,
fuck with the character of the house.
But like,
uh,
the worst,
the worst thing you can do is,
is to take stuff out of your house and replace it with Home Depot Shit.
Um,
I would find some sort of old school hardware store that has just that,
those old doors from,
um,
the time of your house.
You can find those places.
They'll have all the door knobs and all the locks and all of that shit.
You can gradually just go room by room and Redo it.
Um,
and once you're fine with your old doors,
not only the an odd size,
they're also really heavy because,
um,
back then the trees they were cutting down were much older than it's not wet
wood or something that's more dense wood.
I don't really understand it,
but they're super heavy as opposed to all these shit would and fucking crap that
they have down at the,
uh,
home depot.
And the worst thing,
what I like about your email is that you actually seem to love old houses
because there's nothing worse than someone who doesn't give a fuck about it.
Old House buys it just to flip it.
And it's funny,
as they got the house to give it a makeover and everything,
the guys that got it keep all the shit and then they take it down to those
hardware stores and they sell it.
And that assholes like me,
you have to fucking buy it back to fucking make the house look right again.
Um,
all right.
That's my advice.
My advice is the plumbing,
the electrical and your roof.
That's what I would start with.
Then you can deal with all the fucking drafts and all the other bullshit.
MMM.
All right.
I'm sorry guys.
My energy is just fuck,
I got nothing.
All right.
French guy with muscular dystrophy looking for lady advice.
Most share William t rouge.
Uh Huh.
What does that my something bill redhead.
I'm a 39 year old man
and I've take it a fancy to this awesome lady.
We sometimes spend time together working on each other's professional and hobby
projects and we have lots of fun.
The Times we do hang out together to specify we're not coworkers,
but we have a similar circle of friends.
Here's the catch.
She's 27 but I'm 39 and have a disease called muscular dystrophy in case you
don't know what it is.
It's a disease similar to the kid in the wheelchair,
in the gym,
Jeffrey show and set.
Uh,
the differences that in my case,
I'm a hard headed guy,
refused to accept my fate.
It exercise like crazy as a young lad.
While I still had some muscle mass to be able to physically function well above
expectations up to my adult years.
That's great.
Uh,
it's only showed a little in the way that I've walked,
but that's it.
Also being physically disabled has really,
uh,
maybe learn to not take anything for granted and focus on my strengths,
which is really increased by personality skills and gave me game enough to have
a few great relationships,
not lower my standards and it's worked so far.
All right,
so what is the problem sir?
This seems,
it seems all good.
Uh,
anyways,
since I've developed feelings for this 27 year old girl,
I've been hesitant to tell her about it.
If she says no and rejects me,
no big deal.
I've been rejected before,
like most other guys out there and it's something I can handle.
It's basically going to suck for a couple of days tops and everything is fine
after that.
But I guess I'm more afraid if she says yes,
she's still young.
I'm hitting the gym as much as I can to keep myself out of any wheelchair and
crutches and slow this thing down as much as I can.
However,
in the past 10 years,
this disease has really been taking a toll on me,
Jesus Christ.
I think that it's shit that I bitch about this.
Someone dealing with this crap.
I feel my body is going downhill to the point that stairs now look like
mountains.
If I fall,
I can't get up on my own,
which is scary to me.
This girl has been single for a while and has been complaining about being
single,
but she's also young and as her whole life ahead of her and I'm not sure
if I'm still going to be able to wipe,
be able to wipe my own ass in 10 years and I don't want to put someone through
the same pain in the future as that woman had family guy was married to Joe in
the wheelchair.
Uh,
should I invest my feelings and not regret it,
you know,
so at least I tried,
or should I just keep it to myself and not waste a vital part of her life?
She does say yes.
MERCI beaucoup.
The Leer.
Amen.
See Shit.
Just sweet frank quote.
Well,
I don't know what the fuck.
Thanks a lot.
MMM.
Okay.
And same if I am something.
Yeah,
I don't.
What is your see quo,
ma'am?
I mean literally that's I am when?
Same
on gross budget.
Okay.
I'm a big fan of the Bruins and I hate the Montreal Canadians with a passion.
He wrote that in French.
Did Tesla,
Canadians de Monterrey,
all of echo on Paschall.
Just we call mail.
Oh,
girl.
Participant.
They Bruins.
Um,
I would fucking tell her everything you said to me said,
listen,
I got feelings for you.
I really like your partner.
I'm 39 years old.
I have muscular dystrophy.
Yeah.
And I don't want to waste your fucking,
I will know if I'd say all that.
I'd fucking ask around and then,
you know,
if you guys hit it off then I would say all that other shit,
you know?
Does that make sense?
Just don't dump the whole thing on it though.
Still talk about him ever having to wipe your ass in 10 years have figured
that'd be a fucking buzzkill.
MMM.
But you know,
you do want to be fucking up front.
I would,
I would think,
uh,
I got a buddy of mine,
his wife's like that.
She's got the same thing.
I tell her she has ms hectic.
So she has like days where she's like super tired and everything.
Uh,
why do I complain about Dumb Shit?
Lay for this?
People like this out there.
Uh,
sir.
I would ask her out.
Okay.
She's a big girl.
She's fucking 27 years old.
All right.
Ask her out.
Do every year.
You're probably fucking live in more in the moment than most people.
Um,
you know,
fuck.
I mean,
life flies by.
Forget about when you're dealing with some shit that you're dealing with.
So you know,
you're a good guy.
You're actually care about it.
You know,
she care about another person like that.
You don't want to waste the best part of their life dealing with you.
But,
um,
who knows?
Maybe you guys hit it off,
ask her out,
dude,
you know,
but then it moves on to another level.
Then I would talk about that other stuff and see what she says.
Um,
all right.
Drug dealing roommate.
Well,
this is going to be easy.
Um,
move out or kick them up.
All right.
Hey,
Billy,
ball breaker.
I'm from the,
I'm from right outside of Philly.
Another one.
Don't hold it against me.
Dom Arrera is a good shit.
I have nothing against Philadelphia.
I just had a fucking tough show there.
Okay.
And I made fun of Philly.
If I was somewhere else who would've mids in front of somewhere else,
but I don't have a problem with it.
All right.
But I'm 28 and one of my roommates is a deal.
Oh.
And congratulations filling one of the super bowl.
You know,
I can say that now.
The pain's gone away.
Uh,
it was great when I first moved in at 22 and I'll add to do for some pot was
walk upstairs.
But now we've sort of grown up and he's pushing some other shit,
which worries me about the safety of our crib.
Should I approach him and asks him to knock it off or just fuck his girlfriend
and end the friendship.
That's hilarious.
Thanks.
And instead of go fuck yourself.
I wish you the lovely Nia and your baby girl.
Nothing but the best.
See you in AC in October.
Go Birds.
Uh,
go birds.
Is that the Orioles?
Is that the eagles?
There's a lot of birds down there,
man.
Um,
what should you do?
Well,
I don't think when somebody is dealing coke,
uh,
heroin,
what else would be up?
The ecstasy
math.
I don't think you can just say,
hey,
we get knock it off.
Like they have their stereo too loud.
I mean this person has made a decision that this is how they get to earn a
living.
So I would get the fuck out of there is what I would do.
Um,
I would not fuck his girlfriend because he might be trying get his own fucking
drugs is drugs.
Might tell them to do some fucking crazy to you while you're sleeping.
So I would,
uh,
I get the fuck out there is what I would do
because one of these days you're going to be asleep and the door's going to get
kicked in,
is going to be the cops and you're gonna be fucking face down with a boot and
your backend fucking handcuffed.
And then they're going to be like,
did you know he's dealing drugs?
Uh,
know that he's going to write you up.
You,
let's bullshit.
He used to buy them off me.
Uh,
cause he's a piece of shit.
Well maybe he's a good one.
We use a drug dealer with a heart of gold and he gets you out of it.
Yes.
You don't need that the fuck.
Get out of there.
Do you want names on the lease?
Uh,
I would check them out if he doesn't leave that I would just find someplace else
to live.
Um,
all right.
Let me read a little advertising here.
Oh look who's back.
Holly.
Billions of people are using Hadi to save money while shopping online and why
wouldn't they?
It's free.
Takes just two clicks to add to your browser and save you a ton of,
saves you tons of money.
It's ingenious.
One of my absolute favorite things about Hadi is how much better it makes
shopping on Amazon.
Uh,
please personalize this to make it your own.
Oh I am.
Yeah,
buddy magically adds all sorts of useful information right on the Amazon page of
whatever you're looking at.
Just shop like you normally do.
Hadi automatically searches honey automatically searches to 2 million sellers on
Amazon to find the lowest price.
Even shows you item items,
prices changes.
So you can decide if you want to buy or wait for the price to come down.
Oh,
they do this on Amazon.
This is like when he's a little fishes that swims mixed to the big fish.
The big fish eats it,
you know,
sort of tolerated.
If you do decide to wait,
just that hearty drop list and it will notify you if the price drops.
When Heidi gets you 100 he's got your back.
You'll never overpay for anything on Amazon again.
There's no reason to add hardy to your browser today,
not to add it to your browser today.
It's free.
Just takes two clicks to install and we'll make sure you always get the lowest
price and Amazon.
It's fucking free people.
Okay.
Add to your browser for free right now at joined
hardy.com/trends that's join
heidi.com/hardy wow.
All right.
Okay.
You got a couple more here.
Porro
you know,
people after a busy week,
is there anything better than coming home to your,
to a comfortable couch trouble.
Is your couches in that comfortable?
Is it maybe you fell for this Scandinavian aesthetic?
Oh,
you know what I actually did?
We bought some fancy fucking couch.
It's stinks.
It's too many pillows.
You just can't even relax on it.
I hate that couch.
Uh,
maybe the cushions lost their pop for owners ago.
Whatever the case you owe it to yourself to experience the comfort of a borough
couch,
uh,
made from murder,
donkey,
Snow,
Kitty Borough Springs Style and comfort.
To a new level and ships to your door fast and free.
Your relationship with your couch will never be the same burrows burro sofas are
handcrafted in the same factories in North Carolina is other high end retailers,
but burrow delivers them with for much less with their innovative award winning
design if it's been arrogant,
optically designed to allow for multi hour Netflix binges,
triple header game days and late night work sessions.
Customize your borough Surfer Sofa
to match your style
by selecting the color size,
armrest,
height and led color that's perfect for you.
Shipping is fast and free unlike the rest of the furniture industry and that we
mentioned it has a built in USB charger.
This is fucking ridiculous.
I mean like usually used to be like guys like shack would get accustomed couch
cause he's nine feet tall.
The fact that you get to this five foot,
10 inch guy could do this is incredible.
I didn't nobody think of that before with the use USB charger.
Uh,
enjoy 30 days of cozy,
cozy on your comfortable borough risk-free or try out burrow and one of their
partners showrooms today,
customize your own borough and get $75 off your order by going to burrow.com/
[inaudible] that's B u r r o
w.com/bar for $75 off your purchase borough makes the luxury couch for a real
life.
You know who love that Bobby Kelly?
He would fucking love that.
They should hook them up with a couch dead.
It's got a USB port in it.
Did the IMS is right where my arm is dead.
He would love it.
They would talk it up and they'd sell a whole bunch of them as opposed to me
fucking sit here post Ebola sweating like a fucking
guy in the first 48.
All right,
hymns.
It wasn't us.
It was hymns.
66% of men lose their hair by age 35.
Can I tell you guys a fucking hilarious story?
I was at the laugh factory a couple nights ago
and I get off stage and this guy comes up to me
like he does hair transplant and he's got like his card,
right
when I just realized the volumes way down or this fucking thing.
Hello,
hello,
hello.
So the guy fucking,
he comes up to me after my set,
he goes,
hey man,
I can fix that.
I could fix that.
Talking about my bald head.
And he's got this before and after photos gut.
Now here's the thing,
this is the third time.
This same guy has approached me.
All right?
The first time it was,
it was fucking,
I laughed.
It was hilarious,
you know,
cause he said the same thing.
He came up to me,
he goes,
Hey,
I can fix that.
I didn't go to his place and say Amen.
I don't like the way I look.
You know,
he just walked up to me and was so convinced that I thought I looked as awful as
he evidently thought.
I looked,
that he thought it was totally fine to come up to me and just say,
Hey,
I can fix that.
You know?
And I laughed and I said,
Oh man,
I go,
I'm cool.
I liked the way I look.
You know,
I'm actually getting better roles now that I look.
I look like a fucking,
you know,
before I used to,
I look like how doody,
I didn't get good parts.
Now,
you know,
I get to play fucking assholes because I look like one.
I always was one,
but I did always look like one.
So he's like,
oh,
hi.
You know?
Then I ran into when I was down in Largo saved guy and I was just like,
Jesus Christ my buddy.
I'm fine.
Right?
So anyways,
I was doing,
uh,
Kevin Nealon show a Tuesday at the laugh factory and I get off stage and this
fucking guy comes up to me again.
He goes,
hey,
you know,
I can fix that.
And he goes,
I'm the best in the business.
First of all,
dude,
if you're the best in the business,
then like,
why are you fucking running up to comics who just got off stage at a comedy
club,
handing out Your Business Card?
You know,
you like a fucking,
like a I go rapper who just started,
who selling mix tapes out of his fucking coffee,
the best in the fucking business.
You know,
I,
people should be walking into your office as you pose,
you rushing up to people,
right.
So I said to the guy,
I go,
Jesus Christ,
here I go,
this is a third fucking time.
He came up to me,
I'm fine the way I look.
I look fine.
He goes,
you look like an area is what he said.
So I finally,
I just kind of snapped a little bit on it,
you know what I mean?
Cause it was like,
it kind of was not funny anymore.
It was just like,
dude,
like
you're fucking harassing me here.
Yeah.
I don't want,
I'm sorry,
I don't want fucking hair plugs.
What do you do?
You know what it is?
He wants to fuck.
He wants,
he wants a fucking comedian that's got some TV credits that he could do it.
So you can be like,
you know,
just,
just as bill bird,
I'll stand there going,
I love my hair products,
you know,
and his fucking commercial so you can go out and get a boat.
Cause that's where I felt like he was trying to use me,
you know what I mean?
Try to use my bald head so we could go out and get the fucking boat and the big
tinted whore off off of my fucking,
you know,
male pattern baldness.
I thought he was gonna use me like,
like fucking Sharon Osborne did to those people on that fucking album.
Charles finally.
Yeah.
Do I go?
I go enough buddy enough.
What you stupid fucking hair plugs.
They don't want,
I don't want you dumb ass hair plugs.
And he's like,
all right,
sorry.
I appreciate what you do.
And I felt bad because he kind of walked away.
But uh,
how funny is that?
He's fucking slinking up to you in a comedy club.
He does hair transplants.
It's like 10 o'clock at night and he's slinking up to me hand and my business,
his business card.
And he had the fucking nerve to say I'm the best in the business.
The why does this feel so dirty,
sir,
that he's going to fucking ask me if I wanted an abortion.
Um,
alright.
Hymns wasn't us.
It was hymns.
66% of men lose their hair by the age of 35.
Is that right man?
There's a lot of people out there with hair plugs cause you don't see six,
it's almost seven on a 10 guys thing is when you start to lose you to notice
hair loss,
it's too late.
It's easier to keep the hair.
You have to replace their hair.
You've lost,
I asked you why the guys turn to weird solutions or do nothing when they can
turn to medicine in science.
Well cause you just fucking man up and accept your fate.
I Dunno.
Uh,
for hims.com a one stop shop for hair loss,
skincare,
sexual wellness for men.
Uh,
thanks to science baldness can be optional.
Is this true?
A hymns connects you with real doctors and medical grade solution to treat hair
loss,
no waiting room,
no awkward doctor visits.
You sit there and there's all these other balding people in the waiting room.
Save hours by going to,
for him start carb a h I m s uh,
answer a few quick questions.
Doctors will review and Ken's prescribe you product products are shipped
directly to your door.
My listeners get a trial month of hymns for just $5 today,
right now while supplies last.
See websites for full details.
This would cause hundreds.
If you went to the doctors or a pharmacy,
go to for
hims.com/burr.
That's for hymns,
for h I,
ms.com/per for himss.com/pr yeah.
For those of you who don't want to be polled personally,
I don't give a shit.
I actually love having a shaved head.
I'm not even gonna lie to you and I know I look like a freak,
but it's kind of fucking awesome.
Um,
you know,
people think you know Jujitsu.
You don't know Jujitsu.
All right.
Um,
hey,
I can help you with that.
Jesus Christ buddy.
I know he looked bad.
I didn't know I looked that bad that you could just fucking walk.
Right?
I can imagine if he gave boob jobs and he just walked up to some check,
hey,
can I help you with that?
Now you look terrible.
What tits go this way or the other?
Go the other way.
All right,
quip.
The truth is most of us are brushing our teeth.
Rog,
pay you,
brush your teeth,
run a not for long enough and forget to change our brush on time.
All right,
fair enough.
That's because most brands focus on selling flashy gimmicks rather than better
brushing,
but not quit all that.
These guys equipment.
So what makes quip so different?
You may have asked,
maybe you didn't ask,
but I asked for you for status.
Quip is an electric toothbrush.
That's a fraction of the cost of bulkier brushes.
Oh,
that's a guy I didn't know it was electric.
I have a gas toothbrush a while,
still packing,
just I have to cook,
plug it into the stove or plugging in.
There will be electric bill while still packing just the right amount of
vibration to help clean your teeth.
Quip built quips built in timer,
helps you clean,
uh,
for the dentist.
Recommended two minutes with guiding pulses that remind you to switch sides.
Next quips subscription plans are for your health,
not just convenience.
They deliver new brush heads on a dentist.
Recommended schedule every three months for just $5,
including free shipping worldwide.
Quip also comes with a mount that's suctions right to your mirror and unstick us
to use as a cover for hygienic travel wherever you take your teeth.
And finally,
everyone loves quip.
They were on Oprah's oldest,
Jesus,
how full of herself as she.
This is the oldest,
uh,
Oprah's Olis like she literally named it after herself twice named one of Time's
best inventions and is the first subscription electric toothbrush accepted by
the American dental association.
Plus they're backed by a network of over 20,000 dentists and hygienists and
hundreds of thousands of happy brushes.
Use Quip everyday.
Quip starts at just 25 bucks.
And if you go to get quip Qui p.com/bar right now,
you'll get your first refill pack for free with a quip electric toothbrush.
That's your first refill pack for
free@getquipdotcomslashburrspelledgtquip.com slash bar.
All right,
the fuck was I just going to go look up.
That made me want to look something up.
It wasn't for hymns.
I have no idea if I already forget or you forget.
All right guys.
I apologize.
I'm fucking sick.
I am here.
Uh,
just enjoy the music and listen to a half hour of a Thursday afternoon podcasts
where I wasn't fucking sick,
hopefully.
All right.
God bless you.
God bless the United States Republicans,
Democrats,
Libertarians.
You can go to hate groups.
People would love groups,
anti social people.
Well,
people,
people at the back of comedy clubs who had a business cards for hair plugs.
All right.
Have a great weekend.
You cards and I'll talk to you about it.
[inaudible]
oh wow.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
did you enjoy the 4th of July?
You know,
first of all,
before right out of the gate,
right out of the gate,
I want to thank everybody that did some dumb shit with fireworks and it had the
presence of mind to fucking make a youtube video out of it.
You know?
So guys like make it just sit down.
I was laughing my ass off last night I went to bed and I was watching people
shooting bottle rockets out of their ass,
having a Roman candle fights,
seen somebody take one to the face.
Do you know some guy in Maine lit something off on top of his fucking head and
he died instantly.
They were like,
he let off.
They said some a mortar or something fucking insane
at what kind of,
you know,
kind of a fucking asshole would do something like that.
He must have had it.
There's no way.
Everybody knows once you get up to anything like a pack of firecrackers on your
head,
you like that.
That's funny.
You're going to fucking kill your ear drums and you know,
but you're going to survive.
But what?
What do you put an m 80 in his mouth or something?
Well,
I don't know,
Bill.
You fucking brought it up.
All right.
Relax.
What's this look up?
Main guy dies.
Fireworks.
All right.
Shoots off fireworks from top of his head dies instantly.
A 22 year old man was drinking and celebrating the 4th of July.
Happy Birthday to America.
Don't put it on my head.
I'll fucking light it.
Happy Birthday.
Wow.
Michael.
Oh my God.
Somebody calling.
Do it.
Um,
that's how I went down.
22 year old man who was drinking and celebrating the 4th of July.
I tried to launch a firework from top of his head.
Killed him instantly.
Authority said
30.
Said,
you've got to be an authority to say that somebody is fucking dead after the
light.
Something off on their head.
Wait a minute.
Claire.
Claire,
the way.
Clue.
Yes.
Yes,
he is dead.
Well,
they kind of knew that he has brains all over the sidewalk.
Watch your mouth,
woman.
Watch your mouth.
Woman.
It's one of my favorite quotes in sports over the last fucking,
I don't know how many months,
six months.
Watch your mouth woman when that woman called,
uh,
asks,
Lebron won,
it was like to be a punk ass bitch and then that guy's going,
watch your mouth woman,
watch your mouth woman.
And you know,
you would think that the broads would've had such,
which have fucking difficulty with it.
Like you know,
I realized that she said something to Raga Turi tend towards him but that few
excuse go change your brown lady.
All right.
I love that they didn't say anything because even they knew even they knew that
I guide,
you know,
that bitch was out of line.
I'm just talking shit today.
Um,
they won't say what kind of firework it was.
All right.
Apparently he thought that was a great idea that have just when you died in this
stupid fucking way and when somebody starts it off when they start your yield
eulogy off with apparently.
Yeah.
Apparently this guy taught us sticking his head in the garbage disposal was a,
you know,
going to give him a good buzz.
I mean,
I'm sorry to bring it up Claire,
but you know how did even get it in there
all a little ya.
Um,
his friend said they thought they thought they dissuaded him from doing it.
The next thing they knew,
he ignited the firework and he was killed instantly.
What the fuck did he shoot off?
There was no rushing him to the hospital.
There was no Devin left when I got there.
Said 25 year old Cody.
Jesus Christ.
The names of this generation.
Huh?
Devin Cody
jeep wrangler.
Uh,
Devin was the kind of person who would do something stupid.
Absolutely.
He was the kind of person who would pretend to do something stupid to make
people laugh.
Well,
he wasn't faking it.
MMM.
All right.
This is the first fireworks fatality since they legalized fireworks.
January 1st,
2012 while he just fucked it up for the whole state.
It's bad enough.
Everyone's heroin now you're going to give them fireworks.
How many,
what next does isis get their own juice store?
Come on,
people.
Over 80% of bottle rockets are shot out of people's anuses in this state alone.
This needs to stop.
Woo.
That's going on in main street right now in Maine.
Hi.
Do you know me?
Of course you don't
have your regular housewife here in Maine.
My son is on heroin.
My other son shot a Roman candle up his ass.
I'm sorry to be graphic.
He was trying to shoot it out of his ass.
But apparently
his excitement,
oh,
it's getting who?
I mean,
in order to light the wick,
you gotta be able to see it.
So I don't know how many things were done when we were kids.
We just,
we let them and we ran away.
We hit under our desks.
That's what we did.
Devin was a great person.
Um,
and in New Jersey,
a 52 year old man blew up a large piece of his leg below the knee when he set
off a tennis ball size firework in Montana,
Montana,
a 32 year old man was killed at his billings home in a fireworks accident
involving a mortar tube.
Yeah.
All right.
At least there was some sort of mortar around.
I mean mode around,
I mean,
first of all,
when you start lighting off shit where your neighbors starts screaming and
comment,
you know what,
what do you think is going to happen?
Okay,
let's look up a mortar tube here.
Everybody.
I'm learning about fireworks through the death of my fellow Americans.
Um,
I spelt motor.
All right.
Firework,
mortar tubes.
How about some images?
Let me see.
What the fuck these things look like.
Is there some sort of,
all right,
all I see is army guys.
Okay.
Yeah,
that's not good.
You know when,
when the shit you shooting off.
Oh,
there we go.
Well there's one that looks like a little barber shop thing.
What a fucking dope.
He shot that off his head.
You know what probably happened,
I would guess is that there was some sort of discharge from the bottom end of it
in the concussive force.
But it seems like there was no Devaney fucking blew his head off.
No.
Jesus want to wait to start.
I had such a wonderful weekend.
Um,
I didn't mean this when I was talking about funny shit.
I was just talking about,
you know,
people haven't,
Roman candle fights come up.
We all did that shit.
Right?
That's bad.
That is the evolution of all weaponry and all right.
Anything that has an device,
anything that,
that,
uh,
it's supposed to divulge.
Anything that,
that fucking blow shit up.
You just,
you start or do you anything that you can shoot at a target?
It always starts simple.
Let's light it off.
You know,
let's,
let's point it in that direction at the trees,
right?
And then what?
Then you move up to a,
let's torture some insects.
Uh,
let's shoot a bird.
And eventually,
yeah,
because you know,
the way human beings are that we always try to top one another and we get bored,
which is the reason why we went from walking to the horse to the car.
I'm really in deep right now.
I know.
I don't know what the fuck I'm talking about.
Eventually you're going to move to the,
the,
the ultimate prey,
the human being.
You know,
something that can think the same way.
You do something that may have done better in math than you did.
You know,
that's the challenge.
This person passed Algebra.
I did not.
We're both trying to kill one another is,
you know,
first outside,
inside lasts,
going to come into play here when we're out in the woods
are opposite angles being congruent?
Is that going to be the death of me or do I just have that extra something?
Do I want it a little bit more?
Am I able to block out the fifth commandment?
Do I have such a strong religious background that I can hear God's voice in my
head telling me that I'm right telling me to deliver
that animal?
Is that even a man anymore?
It's a fucking handle.
Deliver that animal
in the express lane to its maker.
Right?
Do I have that?
I mean,
it's inevitable.
That's personally why I don't fuck with fireworks.
I don't fuck with fireworks because I know that I am scatterbrained and I get
bored easily and I have 10,000 fucking hobbies and eventually lighting it off in
the driveway is not going to be enough for me.
Okay.
I have neighbors.
I have neighbors that I get along with.
Maybe I'm bored with the fact that I get along with them.
Maybe I want to stop.
Maybe some days you just wake up and you just want to start some shit and you
just happened to have some fireworks that don't just blow up.
They,
they,
they go way up in the air
and you want to shoot somebody.
Right.
Anyways,
uh,
my condolences to anybody,
who knows somebody that died.
Now I don't have any condolences for the people that died cause you fucking dead
and you either dead or I think you were in a better place because someone who's
dumb enough to blow themselves up on the July 4th weekend with their own goddamn
explosive,
I don't think ever had the brains really hurt another human being knowingly.
I never knowingly lied.
Knowingly hurt another fucking human being.
I mean,
honestly,
if you're that fucking stupid,
obviously he'd go out and hurt somebody black,
you know?
Do you really have the mental capacity to understand,
you know,
your actions?
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible]
okay.
What's going on?
It's built burn.
It's the Monday morning podcast for July 5th,
2010 one day after the birthday of this country.
Happy Birthday to America.
Happy Birthday to the USA.
Happy Birthday.
Fuck every other country.
You know,
like a Sadie way.
You fucking Douche bags.
Um,
Jesus Christ.
Happy Birthday to one of the most hated countries on the face of the fucking
planet.
You know,
everybody's shitting on us.
All those fucking World Cup referees.
You know,
people tugging on our shirts,
kicking us in our fucking American balls.
They don't see any of it.
No reason why we're out of the World Cup is because of our foreign policy.
That's why.
That's why we were always off sides.
They never were the gun.
I East does whoever the fuck kicked our ass?
I don't know.
Um,
is the World Cup still going?
Is the world still watching?
Let me ask the world the question.
When your team gets knocked out,
do you tap out and like,
ah,
fuck the World Cup,
you know when you go back to your hut and your grind up corn in that little
guacamole bowl,
do you do that?
Um,
what exactly is done?
Do you continue watching?
I mean,
cause I watch NFL football and when the New England Patriots got raped by the
Baltimore Ravens,
I continued to watch the uh,
the playoffs.
Playoffs.
Yes.
I continued to watch him and uh,
so I was wondering,
you guys are so into soccer.
Yes.
And I am calling it soccer because it's,
it's our birthday this week,
so I'm not going to fucking cow down to you motherfuckers would say call it
football,
you know,
just cause you have a ball and you can only kick it with your foot.
You know,
you guys think you're so clever.
Oh,
that's real football.
Really.
You can kick it with both feet,
can't ya?
Why isn't it ball?
What's the deal?
Um,
look at me with the head of fucking steam.
I'm hung over to feel like shit at a bunch of fucking 4th of July barbecue.
You know,
is it ever good?
Is it ever good?
Oh,
look at the ribs.
All slathered in fucking glistening in fucking fat and you get over there and
you stick your fat American face right into it.
It's all over your face.
Like some fucking two year old trying to eat birthday cake,
you know,
and you run your hands through your hair with it,
get their fucking grizzled Moose look go.
And
it's right.
Then you have sex with some underage girl in a hot tub and you have to fleet of
France because in France sets a fucking acceptable America.
Um,
no,
actually I had some great,
uh,
some great food yesterday.
I just had too much of it.
I just could not stop stuffing my fat face.
I was that kind of full where I couldn't stay in one position.
I was like sitting down and then after a while that wasn't comfortable,
then I'd stand up for a minute and then that wouldn't be comfortable than I had
to like lean on the side of the person's house fucking with the foundation at
that point.
But it was a good time.
Birthday of America.
Actually went to a party,
uh,
there was just a little bit into the Hollywood hills and,
was looking out over la and it's absolutely fucking hilarious.
The amount of illegal fireworks that are shot off,
I don't know,
in every city or an la in particular because I've never had like a bird's eye
view.
And somebody made this hilarious joke that whereas we will looking out,
it looked like when America bombed a United States,
I should say the United States bombed a Baghdad.
And then as we were watching the fireworks going off,
this should have been like a little CNN logo down on the left hand side of our
eyeballs.
And then we all had a big laugh after this person made that hilarious joke.
Now remember that Shit,
you know,
it really made me feel like,
what the fuck
wasn't that a deep thought?
It really made me think,
what the Fuck Gi bill.
I don't think you need to elaborate on that anymore.
I think you really summed it up.
Nah,
just thinking like,
what,
uh,
what would I be doing?
You know,
if,
uh,
if I was sitting in a city that was getting bombed and I worked in like a
fucking,
you know,
I was like,
ah,
I always say a hardware store for once.
Bill,
can he come up with a different job?
Uh,
maybe I put shoes on the bottom of uh,
uh,
lamas,
feats,
feet,
feet.
You know,
there's a lama like is that like an Australian animal or is that from the mid?
Uh,
I always said the Midwest,
the Middle East.
Every once in a while you see a lama in this fucking country and it almost
causes an accident cause you like,
what the fuck happened to that ponies neck?
Um,
not really made me think like I,
I,
I laughed and then I felt bad.
Like where the fuck do I get off laughing?
There's nothing funny about war.
Even if we got to go in and we got to do the shit,
there's just nothing funny about it.
Cause there's a bunch of people on the fucking ground who had nothing to do with
shit.
You know,
they had nothing to do with that maniac.
And is Tom Selleck mustache.
They just trying to fucking survive and then these people come in there to
rescue them and they ended up getting fucking blown up and then here I am,
feed my face like a fat fuck,
you know,
just full of pork,
corn bread,
some Nilla wafer dessert about four beers
and I'm eye balling a slice of pizza watching fireworks in the fucking Hollywood
hills,
Eh,
it looks like bad to Baghdad.
We all should have just projectile vomited right there in a tribute to the the
end of the Roman Empire.
You know when they used to do,
they had those rooms,
those puking rooms.
You just sat there stuffing your face and then you would fucking go in there and
just puke.
Which is another fucking reason why these fucking European clients really need
to sit down and read a history book.
They always talk about how dumb we are,
the exact same shit that they're making fun of us for.
They've all done two,
three times over every fucking one of them.
And I'd rattle off the stats,
but I don't know him
please.
You can tell me that little fucking midget Napoleon didn't.
Stuff is fat face that little fucking Danny Devito look and Douche.
Douchebag.
Huh?
What happened to him?
He went to Waterloo.
What's up with debt?
Fucking Waterloo.
This is like typical fucking American.
Uh,
shit-talking.
I know,
I know the major fucking players and I know the major battle names,
but I have no idea what happened.
He went to Waterloo,
which I believe was at in Austria.
Was that right down the street and Connecticut?
Where the fuck did that happen?
All I know is he went there and he got his little fucking ass kick.
Did he ride pony into battle?
Because he was so little that if he actually fell off a real horse,
it would be fallen off like a fucking skyscraper.
That little douche rubbing his fucking stomach cause he had an ulcer because he
has that little dwarf stomach that can,
if they can't died,
Jess,
more than a couple of strawberries and he's sitting there trying to fucking dive
in and be the big guy.
He won't do you want,
except it won't accept that he's,
he's a little guy with little organs and a little intestinal track.
So what does he do?
He stuffs his face trying to Audi.
It is fucking drill sergeant,
you know,
eaten a Bronto Burger,
whatever they did back then.
Next thing you know he's got an ulcer and this now pepto,
there's no fucking pepto,
you know,
it's the 15 hundreds I did that on purpose just for all you fucking snobs.
I know he was around in the 18 hundreds wasn't,
he was at the 17 hundreds I dunno.
One of those ones where the,
where you're fucking,
you're wore too much makeup,
you know,
and you're curled up your hair like that chicken little house on the prairie
that I was making a reference to,
Nelly,
Nelly Olson,
who's got a fucking book coming out,
doesn't she?
You know,
seeing now that's how you do it as a child star when you fall off.
She never got involved in drugs.
You know,
she just kept fucking living off of her residuals.
Granted she had the options,
cause evidently that series plays all over the world.
You know,
but now she writes a book,
you know,
you just keep milking it.
You just write a book still Nelly Still Nellie after all these years and you
answer the same fucking questions over and over again.
How close was that character to their real you?
If they're a little bit of Nellie in you,
if they're a little bit of Nelia and all of us,
you know,
and people wonder why those celebrities end up snapping in those fucking
interviews.
Somebody sent me a youtube video this week about Mel Gibson who's having another
rough week by the way.
He still no,
no,
no audio tape of him being a Douche has really come about.
I think that's just the,
uh,
the ex girlfriend claiming he did some shit like that.
Either that or he's got a fucking unbelievable fucking lawyer,
which you know,
could be either or.
But uh,
what the hell is it?
Where the fuck is he youtube video.
Oh Man,
I was on such a role.
What is my voice hurt?
Like I did a bunch of,
oh,
there it is.
Like I did a bunch of shows this weekend.
Was it because I was drunk yelling at people.
Um,
all right.
Uh,
Mel Gibson's the,
here's a youtube video,
look up Mel Gibson,
Dean Richard Calls Dean Richards and asshole.
And somebody asked me my opinion on it and I think he was,
I think it was well within his fucking right to call him an asshole.
Uh,
basically what happens is this guy goes to passive aggressive route where
Malcolm's onto hype is movie and Dean's like,
you know,
hey,
it's great to have you here,
but blah,
blah blah.
And you can see Mel Mel's already defensive because he's got that anti-semite
rant hanging over his fucking head.
So He's already fucking just,
you know,
he can say it in his face like,
ah,
fuck,
let me just get through this fucking interview with this guy bringing this shit
up.
So the guy,
the we fucking soft sells of whatever he did it passive aggressive.
Oh,
this about the movie that about the movie.
And then he goes,
yeah,
you know,
it's kind of some familiar ground.
I feel like I'm visiting an old friend,
which is a really country way of saying like,
yeah,
I've already seen you do this movie before,
but he doesn't come out and say it.
Mel Handles all of it with grace.
And then finally in the,
in the end,
you know,
he fucking suckers and with the overhand right going,
oh yeah.
Uh,
so how do you think the public's gonna receive you?
And,
and he goes,
well,
what do you mean?
He goes,
you know,
with a,
some of your troubles that you've had in the past.
And Mel goes,
uh,
well,
you know,
my life's kind of been a roller coaster a,
and the guy just keeps going and goes,
what exactly are you talking about?
And he just fucking,
because you know,
when you got drunk and blah,
blah,
blah.
And he brings that shit up again.
And Mel's like,
dude,
he spent four fucking years,
Yada,
Yada.
This is my thing.
It's like one of those deals where Mel Gibson,
he did say it.
So,
but my thing is if you're going to fucking trash the guy for it,
just go ahead and trash them.
Don't sit there and act like you're the guy's fucking buddy.
And then out of nowhere hit him over the head with it.
So he ends up calling the guy and asshole the guy is an asshole.
And uh,
the other point is that Dean Richards,
Guy,
I swear to God,
if you tapped his phone,
he tapped that guy's fucking phone.
You don't think that,
that he would say anything that would involve some sort of,
uh,
apology.
I'm just really tired of people acting like they don't have any sort of fucking
issues whatsoever.
I'm not saying that you're a straight up fucking racist or right beginning,
you never caught yourself.
You know,
you're walking down the street,
it's late at night,
you see some of,
of a particular race.
And what do you think?
You think in the worst shit,
you know,
and then it turns out for some reason you have to interact with them and then
they're the exact opposite of what the fuck you thought your were.
They were,
I mean,
I dunno,
I'm just sick of people.
When somebody does something like that,
everybody gets to be like holier than Thou and act like a,
they don't think any fucked up thoughts.
And secondly,
second,
second of Lee.
Second of all,
I think I'm on third of all at this point.
And,
and,
and uh,
see my,
my third point,
I'm just gonna switch between numbers and letters here.
Mel Gibson has a lot of fucking issues,
right?
So how do you cure the guy of these fucking hateful ish issues?
You fucking drag them across the Goddamn Coles and rub his fucking face in it.
I mean,
I,
I really don't think that that's going to make a guy with fucked up thoughts
really sit back and reflect,
you know,
I mean,
it's up to that dude,
whether he wants to sit back and reflect,
but,
you know,
I don't think like a,
I'm trying to think of a good fucking analogy.
I got it.
Like when I lived in Boston,
I absolutely fucking hated the Yankees and I fucking hated their fans.
And then when I moved down in New York and I had to interact with them,
you know,
they weren't as bad,
but I still thought that they were Douche bags at the end of the day.
All right.
That was a bad example.
Whatever.
I fucking waiting the podcast,
you know what I'm saying?
At some point I think the public has to forgive Mel Gibson,
particularly anybody that he went off on.
I think he should be a nice guy to him and then he can realize,
wow,
what the fuck was I thinking?
Here's so and so.
He's part of the group X,
Y and Z that I went off on.
I really was a drunk Douche bag,
but I think if you're a fucking racist comment and you think that shit,
I think mace mostly,
maybe you'll,
you'll probably remain that way,
but if you're actually truly trying to not be a racist content anymore,
if the group that you attacked is a fucking asshole to you,
not a fucking asshole.
That's a bad,
but like just constantly is yelling at you.
I don't,
I don't see where you think that that guy is going to turn the fucking corner.
You know,
where the fuck are you calling us?
Douchebags you fucking cunt.
Oh yeah.
What was I thinking?
You know what I mean?
Does that make any sense whatsoever?
I don't fucking note.
Whatever.
Look it,
I can separate the racist guy from his movies.
Uh,
who's kidding?
Who it's hard to.
It's a,
it's a fucking difficult thing,
you know?
And the guy did say it,
so I guess he does deserve that.
But you know,
I just thought that was a really fucking pussy ass way.
I just thought if you watched the interview,
the guys being really passive aggressive,
he's taking swipes at the movie,
you know,
saying it's like,
oh,
this is,
he's basically saying,
Mel,
this is you doing shit.
I saw you do 20 years ago.
What's up with that?
But he put,
he was saying it in this,
you know,
I just felt like I was a visiting an old friend,
you know?
What about doing the stunts?
Is it harder to do the stunts now that you're older,
you know,
that type of ship?
Yeah.
Dean yet is harder.
Is it harder for you to see your Dick when you sit down?
When you take a shit,
you old fat.
Fuck yeah,
we're getting older.
What is your point?
I'm trying to sell a movie here.
You're taking me out at the knees.
Why?
If you would just going to take me out at the knees.
Why didn't you just do a rant on your show rather than have me get up at fucking
in the goddamn morning for you to pretend like you actually respect me on some
level.
I Dunno.
I guess that's my problem with the video.
Like I uh,
those of you listening to my podcast,
you know how much I hate passive aggressiveness.
Um,
it's just a,
I dunno,
it's really a,
uh,
it's one of the bitchy qualities you can have as a fucking human being.
You know,
if you're going to be a con,
stand there flat footed with your shoulders squared up and just hit them.
100 files going to say full force.
Just like fucking Jeff Farmer who I'll be getting to later full force with being
a cunt towards them.
You know,
it's like you have a piss somebody off,
you cut them off in traffic and they're behind you and you look in their face
and you know they're mad at you,
right?
And you drive for like two,
two and a half miles,
and then you make a rightness still going straight.
And as you make a right,
they drive by and then they beep at you.
You know,
plan is,
they go by
that,
that type of shit.
Lean on the fucking whore.
The second I do something right,
don't wait till I make a right turn and you could fucking beep at me and then
drive away Jesus Christ.
That was it.
That what?
You know what?
That was a nice God damn example.
There was really a nice example.
Um,
anyways,
I went out and I bought some new clothes this weekend.
Everybody,
it's,
it's Kinda one of those weird things when you become an adult where,
uh,
as a kid,
I don't know about you guys.
I know these kids nowadays are all fucking spoiled with their iPads,
you know,
and they have box of condoms or whatever the fuck they get at school every
goddamn day.
Um,
it was just picturing people like 18 listen to this,
thrown their hands up.
Like what do we don't get that?
Um,
yeah,
there's that weird thing when I was a kid,
you got,
you got new clothes once a year,
you know,
Christmas didn't count because those were from your grandmother and that was
pleased.
Beat the shit out of me.
Clothes.
Um,
I guess you got a couple of things,
but like basically you got new clothes at the beginning of every year.
That's how I worked in my family beginning of every year.
You went down to the fucking Levi store,
you got like three different pairs of fucking corduroys and you got a new pair
of sneakers and you got like three shirts and that was it.
See you next September.
They're fuck,
oh,
that was it.
That was it.
And the rest was hand me downs from your older brothers and sisters,
not sisters,
older brothers or whatever,
or oldest sisters.
If you're abroad,
you know,
trying to fucking make this,
this podcast for everybody.
Uh,
why don't I just sound like fucking Dana carvers carved visa George Bush.
That sounded like that to me.
Trying to do the podcast for everybody,
not Gani dead.
Um,
wouldn't be prudent.
That's a terrible impression bill.
Once you shut the fuck up and talk about you stupid clothes,
fine.
I will my podcast,
I'll fucking talk about whatever I want to talk about.
We think about that.
Um,
yes,
he got and that was it for the whole fucking year.
And you sneakers look good until about September 30th.
And then,
and then that was it.
And that was fucking it.
But,
uh,
but the weird thing as an adult is,
you know,
you think I'm going to say that you buy clothes more often.
The reality is is you don't,
you don't,
you let a couple of school years go by and,
uh,
then one day,
you know,
you have to go to an event that you haven't gone to in awhile,
like say like a barbecue.
I can't remember the last time I went to a fucking barbecue.
And you start fishing out your barbecue clothes from the bottom of your God damn
dresser drawer.
You know,
bring a bathing suit.
I pull out this fucking bay.
Then students got a Mustang,
Mustang,
I can't even talk this week.
He has a mustard stain from like fucking back when Clinton was in office and I
don't know what it was now,
like I'm up on bathing suits styles,
but I could just tell it was not in style anymore and everything was just
fucking linty and old looking and all that shit.
So I was like,
ah,
God damn it,
I got to go to the fucking mall.
So I go to the mall,
I had to buy some new sneakers and I go into the foot locker and they're selling
Lakers tee shirts that says 16 for,
this is Los Angeles Lakers,
16 fucking NBA championships on it.
And the footlocker guy comes up dressed like a ref,
you know,
and he comes up to me and he's just like a,
hey sir,
is there anything I can help you with?
I said,
yeah,
you can fix that tee shirt right there and have it say Los Angeles Lakers,
11 NBA championships.
And he's like,
what are you talking about?
I'm like,
cause you won.
Your first five is the Minneapolis Lakers.
All right,
sick Los Angeles Lakers.
It should say Minneapolis slash Los Angeles Lakers.
She got that Los Angelenos.
Those first five championships are not yours,
so why don't you fucking cave in your chest a little bit down to about 11
championships and I'll keep mine way the fuck out there with my 17 NBA
championships from the Boston Celtics,
all of them in Boston.
Are you guys still confused about that?
La?
Think about how many times have you burned down your city.
You haven't burned it down 60 times.
Your burned it down 11 times.
You fucking asshole.
Classic people from Los Angeles just pat in their fucking resume.
You're a fucking PA on a project.
All of a sudden you're an executive producer.
You win 11 championships as the Los Angeles Lakers and all of a sudden now
you're walking around with 16 NBA Championships.
You got a lot of fucking nerve.
Just like tiger woods wife,
you got a lot of fucking nerve Stan the fuck down.
I don't know.
I can't remember if I talked about this last week,
uh,
on the podcast.
But after watching some world cup soccer and watching these fucking pansies,
every time anybody comes near them,
flopping around,
like they just got fucking tasered.
I was like,
you know what?
I Bet Pau Gasol,
that's where he learned his flopping around on the fucking court out there.
Either that or used to watch a fishing show.
I can't figure out what he just outgrew the sport,
the big fucking goof.
Ah,
his fucking face.
How do you fucking start squinting bef before you even start driving to the
Goddamn rim?
If Pau Gasol ever puts out a ringtone,
that's what it's going to sound like.
He found me.
Oh,
I just can't get over it.
I just can't get over that.
We fucking lost to those assholes
and Colby choked and POW choke.
They both choked in game seven and no one's ever going to fucking remember.
If it wasn't for this podcast,
I'm going to be bringing it up for you is
um,
all right.
Anyway,
so it's July everybody.
We're over the hump another year.
Another year is flying by.
All right.
And I want you guys to realize that it is July 5th.
All right?
In the end of August is coming.
So you make sure that you do something fun every God damn weekend.
Alright,
senator,
how about you guys?
As you get older,
I don't know what the fuck happens.
It's May and you're like,
oh my God,
summer's coming.
And then the next thing you know it's,
it's,
it's over and you're like,
I didn't do shit.
I didn't do one fucking fun thing.
All I did was work and right as you get mad and you're going to actually
examined how the fuck you let another summer slip away,
all of a sudden it's preseason football and you get so fucking excited that you
forget that you wasted another summer.
Yeah.
As you guys a question,
when was the last time you went inner tubing down a Goddamn river?
Isn't that what you're suppose to do in some sort of wrangler Jean cutoffs.
Oh,
by the way,
by the fucking way,
speaking of wrangler,
do you want to know why that,
that,
that um,
reference was in my fucking head when I went,
I'm really bringing the voice down for this story.
Everybody,
when I went to go shopping yesterday,
you know,
which is one of the great activities you can do with your girlfriend when you
need new clothes.
I mean if you ever just want to watch your girl's face just light up,
just say that to her.
Hey Sweetheart,
you want to go shopping?
Oh my God.
He finally gets me.
Guess who I am?
I would love to go.
So we go over to the fucking mall and I'm like,
alright,
I need to buy some clothes,
some barbecue clothes,
some clothes that I can wear hanging out of barbecue.
So I won't get trashed at this fucking barbecue cause it's going to be a bunch
of comedians there.
I'd already get a bunch of shit if there was a bunch of pipe fitters down there
or whatever,
they would already be breaking balls.
So I got to go down there.
I gotta be looking.
All right,
so we go to the mall and she takes me into target or is the women call it
Tarjay.
That's the little fucking,
oh my God,
we're being frisky joke.
And this is the amazing thing about women is women can go into a target and find
something and,
and uh,
make it work as they say.
God,
I can't believe I know that fucking expression.
Okay.
I'm really gonna have to bring up my excuse here.
My girl watches that fashion show and I actually am aware of that guy with the
glasses who goes make it work.
Um,
and this is basically how it works.
My girl watches those reality shows and uh,
I might even bring her in here.
Hey,
Neha.
Yeah,
you want to come in on the podcast?
All right.
Knee is coming in on the podcast.
Everybody.
Yeah,
I'm going to explain basically how it works.
One.
I uh,
the lovely Nia,
everybody.
I was actually,
I was talking about how when I needed some new barbecue clothes,
right.
Um,
that you took me to target and I was beginning to say that target,
like there's something about women that you can go into a target and actually
whatever you find you can make it work.
And then I realized that that was the saying of that gun.
Yes.
So now I'm feeling like work.
Yeah.
Like people can be like,
you actually watched those shows.
How long do I last when I watched those reality shows with you?
About five minutes before I kick you out.
Kick you kick me out.
Why?
Because you act like a dick.
What do you mean?
I don't have like a dick.
I start,
I start trashing the people on the show.
Yeah.
Well you make little jokes and stuff and it's funny and then you get annoying
and you hinder my ability to enjoy it.
It's like kick you out.
All right.
I want to defend my thing.
So she brings me into target.
I thought t to go.
What's that?
I thought we were going in there for you to find workout clothes,
workout clothes,
which,
so she brings me into,
into the corner of the store and she shows me these fucking,
I didn't even know champions still made workout clothes and they've since
changed their logo and she's like,
ah,
look at these,
you like these workout clothes.
And it literally looked like the kind of shit you'd wear.
Like,
you know when you get,
you get arrested for something and then seven years later when they let you out
of jail,
they give you your clothes back.
That's what the fuck it looked like.
Basketballs worth.
Yeah.
And I said,
yeah.
And they're also like that Jordan level where it's all the way down to your
calves still.
If they don't realize that it's actually,
they've,
they found a happy medium between the Larry Bird's and the Michael Jordan.
Jordan.
Yeah.
Which is a little bit above the knee.
And uh,
so what did I do?
I went in there and I said,
I'm,
I was in there for like three seconds.
I'm like,
yeah,
I'm not buying any shitty,
really irritate.
You got fucking mad at me because belt,
whenever we go shopping together and I have suggestions or whatever,
you just walk in,
look for not even three seconds.
You're being very generous to yourself.
You walk in,
you're like,
I'm not fucking doing this.
You don't even look.
You don't even take the time.
I was right,
but I was right.
They had tank tops next to like Dickies said like,
yeah,
like I want to get a snake out of fucking toilet and then go play some hope.
It's not,
that's not for men.
Target is not for men.
I don't think it is unless,
unless they're getting staff buy,
buying can openers and beer glasses.
That's what the fuck they're getting.
Then I bought,
what are they going to buy?
Slacks.
They had lots of slides.
They are lots of tee shirts and stuff that you could have gotten,
you know?
Oh yeah,
they,
I could've got some sneakers in there too with the Velcro fucking snap things
over the front is if to say I,
you know,
I lost part of my foot in a boating accident.
They don't need to be that expensive.
If it's workout clothes.
Of course you want to look nice,
but you don't have to spend a ton of money on,
I don't know.
I don't believe in that unless you're a fucking tennis player.
If I were a tennis player,
I would want cute tennis outfit,
but if it's just me in here doing my stupid Jillian Michaels workout,
I don't know.
This is my thing like,
well,
how the fuck did me going into getting some shit for going to a barbecue slash
some new workout clothes?
Go to me wanting to buy a cute tennis outfit.
I didn't realize that this was supposed to be an outfit that transitioned you.
It's not an outfit.
It's not an outfit barbecue.
I didn't realize that was what brought you in here to try to save face because I
said make it work and now you're just,
I'm just further into the muck bike.
All right.
That's it.
People.
I had to go to a barbecue and I went to the mall and I bought a cute outfit.
You did Mike,
you Nafa.
You looked really nice yesterday.
Yes,
I did.
I look respectable,
although I did the classic old guy thing where I had the brand new sneakers in
the older socks.
You know what's funny is that when you were putting them on for half a second,
I wanted to suggest that you wear socks that were a little bit lower so that you
wouldn't see so much of the sock.
They were ankle level.
I know,
but you could've gotten him like a little bit lower.
So I don't know.
And have that little ball on the back of them.
When did those become guy socks?
Those Chris Everett Lloyd's back.
But they're just the low socks you see of the sneaker and not so much the side.
I gotta be honest with you and as I dunno,
I have people write in about this.
I feel like when you wear shorts,
sneakers and socks,
if there's too much socks showing,
eh it's,
it gets a little,
I don't know.
Dorky.
Yeah.
Jesus.
You know this just class.
So you,
so you basically,
I'm the guy you love and you let me walk around this barbecue yesterday looking
like a Douche.
Fill this your own way to keep the women's away from me.
Is that what you were doing?
Didn't look like a Douche.
She looked really good and be anytime awhile.
I don't know if we should get into this,
but why?
Why not?
What are we going to have an argument on here?
Do you think these people give a shit about us?
We're trying to fill up and do an hour of their day.
I think they how mad they are that they have to work July 5th and the company
across the street has a cool boss hog are actually closed.
What is the problem now?
I just,
you know,
if I were to make a suggestion like that,
you really knew what to fuck.
Almost
[inaudible] is that what I sound like?
Well,
I remember making a suggestion yesterday and that didn't work out too good
either.
That's why I didn't want to bring it out.
Oh,
you don't want to talk about that.
You don't want to talk about the fact that I said your dress was a little linty
l your dress was a little linty.
Yes.
And we can then,
and then when I came home and I changed,
and this is,
this is the hardest,
like help guys out here.
You ever,
do you know what the hardest fucking thing is when is when standing up now I'm
standing up now,
cause I want to make a point here is it had nothing to do with you.
I was just,
I was,
you know,
I was like,
you know the dress,
you just dress up in a just a little bit too long.
It's just one of those ones you throw over.
Look at me.
I'm already getting nervous trying to explain to you.
I said I'll buy you another one.
And then the next thing you know that was just like at fucking,
there was,
there was the meltdown.
I'm all set and I use a meltdown offline.
Started crying in the mall on the birthday of our country.
I don't give a shit about the birthday of this country.
I don't,
sorry everyone.
Wow.
I'm African American.
There's still a little annoyance there,
so I'm not exactly,
yeah,
America's freedom.
Fuck you.
Gotta to take it all the way to there.
Right.
Anyway,
wait a minute.
This isn't about that.
Oh my God.
Do you realize the emails we're going to,
they're going to get,
well,
why don't you go the fuck back to fucking Africa?
They should say it.
Go ahead.
Let them get it all out there,
but I know Gil,
you go Mel Gibson's,
get it all out there.
Let's not mince words here that Jesus Christ in the eight you know,
I try to keep it light and you just went Fox News on me.
You just went Fox News on me or whatever.
No,
actually no.
The ultra liberal fun back to haunt me.
Yeah.
If I become a successful actress that this is going to be played on some sort of
website.
A Ne hates this country.
That's not what I'm saying,
but anyway,
what are you saying?
I'm just saying that you know,
wait a second.
When people celebrate 4th of July,
are they really like eating their barbecue and drinking their beer?
Thinking about this country and our forefathers and would it really?
No,
they're not.
They're just like,
Yay,
I don't have,
I don't have work tomorrow and I get to get drunk.
Yeah.
Most of them on the text messages telling people how before the July,
like it's Christmas.
No one cares.
I don't think
your popularity.
Nia was through the roof now podcast and now,
you know,
it was funny was I will listeners on a journey up and down.
I don't wash in a rollercoaster.
That's what,
that's exactly what Mel Gibson just said.
I just watched that thing and he just said that.
She just said that shit.
No,
there's fucking no passive aggressive Douche bag was sitting there going,
uh,
w w was came on acting like he wanted to talk about his movie,
but he really just wanted to sort of steer it back around to that time you went,
you went off.
So,
and then he was,
he was going like a,
he goes,
well,
you know,
you don't want,
when I saw your movie,
I just felt like I was visiting an old friend that we were on some,
some familiar ground.
He was basically saying like,
yeah,
I've seen this fucking movie before.
But,
but he was doing it in the sing song.
He fucking voice very jerky.
So he starts with that and then then he asked and he asked him about doing
stunts.
Is it harder to do now that you're an old fuck?
Was basically the subtext.
And then in the end he goes,
how do you think America's going to receive you?
So then Mel had to play it off like he didn't know what he was talking about.
And then he basically brings it around and then the end,
Mel calls him an asshole.
And at one point when Mel was saying,
he goes,
well,
you know my life has been sort of a roller coaster.
He did say that.
So Nia,
do you want to try to,
I didn't mean to.
So you think like Mel Gibson.
All right,
well look,
I'm not going to lie to you.
You guys did have a rough couple of hundred years there at the beginning of this
country.
Started off a little slow for you guys.
What do you mean 400 it wasn't a couple hundred.
It was,
it was a couple hundred.
It was go online.
Right now near this fucking country is only 230 fucking four years old.
It is.
Yeah.
1776 that's when he officially became America.
That was 400 years.
400 Nia.
It's the two thousands right?
So that would be the 16 hundreds you guys came over with those fucking pilgrims
in their butter.
What do they make?
Oh,
their oil.
What?
What do we use the pilgrim as a,
it was one of this old colony gas.
Nobody remembers those guys showing my age.
I don't know.
They came over with smallpox.
Infected blankets.
You gave him to the Indians.
That's all I know.
Who did the pilgrims on the Nina.
The pinta in the Santa Maria.
No,
no,
no.
We didn't do the smallpox thing.
Wait,
wait,
wait.
You're getting ahead of yourself?
We came over and we starve to death and then we acted like we were friends with
the Indians going,
hey man,
like how do you,
how do you make [inaudible] sit down and have dinner with us?
Call it thanksgiving.
Yeah.
Why don't I will kill you?
Why don't you teach us how,
right?
How to make,
how to survive out here.
And then once they did that,
we would just like,
wouldn't it be awesome if we all lived here and they didn't
Hae Jebidiah why don't you sneeze into the fucking blankets and we'll give it to
him.
Yeah.
We went germ warfare way back in the day.
And then we gave him like $48 for the entire Midwest.
The Louisiana purchase.
No,
we did we buy that off of France?
Yeah.
Bought that off of France,
but whatever.
So that the French word over here murdering the Indians,
weren't they?
I don't fucking know.
All I know is they got,
yeah.
So I guess is proving that we both can,
we don't know.
Shit.
Don't know shit.
There's a bunch of people judging us right now.
Um,
well it's one of those things like,
you know,
like that type of shit you learn and it just really doesn't come up in your
everyday life.
You know,
as I figured out how to get these bankers off my goddamn back,
the Louisiana purchase really doesn't come up,
I guess.
Can you name,
can you listen?
Let's see.
How dumb we are.
Can name as many American wars as you possibly can.
Okay.
World War One and two.
Bang.
Don't went with the easy ones right off the bat.
Civil war,
uh,
the Iraqi war.
Operation Freedom as
the Cold War.
Was that an actual wow.
Wow.
My girlfriend's an idiot.
Wait a minute.
I'm not an idiot,
but no,
I'm not very good at history.
All right.
I admit it.
I'm not,
I don't know anything about it.
So then what are your trash in the country for?
I Dunno.
Can you just tap out and just say you're sorry.
Just say you.
Sorry.
Just say,
just say,
because what are you doing?
Do you think it's any better anywhere else?
Do you,
when you really look around the world,
where are they?
Where is everybody really holding hands and all getting along?
Isn't it everywhere that there's,
they have and the have.
Okay,
let's talk about Sweden.
Let's,
Ah,
let's talk about how you own,
they only universal health care.
They only let good looking people in Stockholm,
Sweden,
and the second we got out of there,
we took the train out of there.
All of a sudden,
that's where they kept all the Brunettes,
all those Muslim looking dudes in that shitty fucking gray communists.
Look in mall we went to,
you remember that shit.
Well,
I mean,
isn't it sort of like Manhattan now?
That's not a good example,
but maybe in more,
you know,
you know international Richard Cities,
you have people who yes.
Can Afford to get their hair done once a week and have gym memberships and nice
clothes and eat it.
Yes.
Just like here,
like here.
I know it's the same thing.
It's the same thing.
All right.
You don't think those Blondie's looked down on the brunettes and then a Brunette
Sco,
brunettes,
Sweden.
Yeah.
Within,
where the fuck were they?
They were there.
Yeah.
We were both walking down the street and Stockholm going,
Jesus Christ,
everyone's beautiful.
Look at Deca.
Yeah,
I felt like a fucking Mongrel.
There was hot guys working on h and m like model guy.
Like,
like uh,
like movie star looking chicks working at like a newspaper stand.
Yeah.
And then what?
Remember that we got outside this Nia,
I'm telling you every where you go,
you go over to England,
they got their Rothschild's,
they got their royal fucking family.
You know,
they weren't even mingle with those fucking people who work on the tube or
whatever the fuck they do.
Right.
And then people in London,
they look down on people in Liverpool and people in Liverpool looked down on
people in another city.
But I only know two cities in England.
Right,
right.
Yeah.
So there you go.
It's all the same shit.
What do you think are going to go?
You're going to,
you're going to move to where you're going to go to Canada and they're going to
be nicer.
I apparently,
they are very nice in Canada.
It's a really,
really,
you think so?
I don't know.
He just through Toronto out there,
every time anyone brings up Toronto,
they have nothing but nice things to say about it.
So,
but no,
I've never been there.
So you know,
this was supposed to be a nice,
cute segment.
I didn't take that.
It was really,
it really wasn't supposed to be about Oh,
you and your clothes and going to target.
Next thing you know,
you,
yeah.
Next thing you know,
you were having a reality moment.
Hissy fits.
I am thrown at celebrating the birthday of this country.
Okay.
I am,
I am so mad at America right now.
I'm not mad at America.
This is a great country.
Of course it is.
But See,
took you 20 minutes to come back around.
It is.
I do,
I live,
I like living here.
I don't have a pro.
I'm not just like this fucking cook for you.
Sucks man.
I'm not liking
me.
And let me tell you something here.
That's how we talk.
Whenever we talk about hippy,
really liberal people,
we always,
we always end our centers with me.
And Yeah,
m y a,
N O and if you guys want to see the ultimate Hippie,
here's a,
here's a good,
uh,
rainbow guy.
Youtube video of the week.
Look up.
Uh,
you sent,
you sent me Yosemite,
Yosemite,
Yosemite mountain giant double rainbow.
This guy said double rim.
Yeah.
You guys [inaudible] you have to watch this video.
This guy,
if he's on drugs,
he's the coolest guy ever.
But if he's sober,
he's one of the biggest,
he's such a Douche.
She had to live in the wilderness.
He basically sees uh,
a full on double rainbow.
On Rainbow.
Yeah.
What does it mean?
And he starts fucking car.
I don't want to read it.
I don't ruin it for you.
Um,
here's another one.
I have like,
this is unbelievable week for you.
Two videos here.
Uh,
Jones's good ass barbecue and foot massage.
Oh look that one up Jones,
good ass barbecue and foot massage.
You've got to see that.
And this is one of the creepiest videos I've ever seen.
Creepy,
weird hippie yoga teacher slash.
Farmer.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
You got to look at that one and a terrifying.
And then possibly my favorite
I've ever seen.
If you guys are wrestling fans,
you guys know how I love Rick Flair.
And when he got on the mic and started talking about who he was going to fight
that weekend,
there was nobody better.
You got to see this lookup,
best wrestling promo ever jump in Jeff Farmer,
this guy is the worst I've ever seen any so and that,
that's like four videos.
Like,
like the mean gene guy is going,
jumping Jeff last week that you know,
we're going to actually do the gpt boy Jhumpa Jeff last week you've got attacked
by so and so,
uh,
you know,
how do you know?
And,
and he really,
he really beat you down and then you're supposed to jump in.
Well let me tell you something,
come on this Saturday at the royal rumble,
but he doesn't,
he just goes,
you know,
and he really beat you down and the guy just goes yup.
And then there's just
long awkward pause.
Well,
he turned the tables on me in a way that I didn't appreciate it and you just got
to see it.
There's like four of them.
And uh,
then there's another person who actually,
uh,
what is this one?
Fat nerd.
Wow.
Gangster threatens X.
Not at all.
One,
that's all one g and then it says guilties,
whatever that is.
And if they spelled it wrong or if that's a video game,
it's basically,
it's some really fat woman who,
uh,
got kicked off playing video games and she's a really pissed off about it and
she starts showing some of the moves she learned in Jujitsu block strike.
It's really bad.
Just,
just check all of those out.
But uh,
it's almost getting to the point where I have to wrap up the podcast.
So Nia,
you fucking Pinko commie.
Thanks for coming on the podcast in spewing your fucking hatred.
Hatred.
I'm not a Cami.
I love this country.
It's like a love,
not love,
hate.
I know.
Yeah.
You got the love hate thing,
which I'll,
I'll never,
I'll never be able to appreciate it as a white guy because my life is,
it's awesome in this country.
Perfect.
Anything you want,
it's tremendous.
I get a USA today and a bag of cash every day from the government.
Yup.
You're a white male,
ages 18 to 45.
Oh,
it's perfect.
It's,
it's a,
yeah.
Bankers don't fuck me over.
Nobody's,
you need it to be,
it's tremendous.
No,
you love living in this country.
You love the fact that you can,
you know,
make something out of yourself.
You can really come from nothing.
And that's the thing,
you know,
you know immigrants come,
you're really trying to save it right now
who don't speak a word of English.
And then they do rise up amongst the ranks and have great likes.
Cesar Milan,
the dog whisperer.
Look at him.
Yes,
he,
he did it.
He came into this country illegally.
Right.
Then he swam across the river like 12 dogs tied to his bad.
Isn't that how we came in?
I think he did come illegally,
but he did become legal.
But so he's becoming,
yeah.
So there you go.
He has to,
I mean like how much money he's making.
Tyler Perry jumping Jeff Farmer Tyler.
Billy Carter are immigrants,
Huh?
Well,
yeah.
Oh,
immigrants.
All right.
Uh,
uh,
that fucking English speaking lady on.
So you think you can dance Arnold Schwarzenegger.
Arnold Schwartzenegger.
Yeah,
look at him.
Kelly.
40 yards in California.
It's pretty impressive.
Yeah.
You love this country.
But there are some things that bothered me about it.
Like everyone else.
Everyone else has various issues with this country too.
Maybe I'm not supposed to talk about it cause it's the 4th of July.
It's one of those things.
I know what you're saying.
Look you guys,
you know,
thank you.
You know,
you go down to the corner store next to no 12 cops are pulling you out of your
car.
You know,
beating the crap out of you.
I get it.
Sure.
Yeah.
That doesn't happen to me.
I get annoyed this how spoiled I am as a white guy.
I get annoyed at airport security when they want,
when they want me to go through the little misty thing.
Are you a terrorist?
I get so fucking mad and I remember in that moment go and like,
why?
I can't imagine how those Mexican dudes in Arizona are feeling right now getting
pulled over every five seconds yet.
I'm sure they're not excited about 4th of July this weekend.
Well,
what are you,
what are you supposed to do?
What are you supposed to do?
You know what?
I don't understand social profile.
I don't know.
You know what?
I think once the sun goes down and your outside,
everybody racially profiles you do you have to think the worst of people so you
can get to your car in the parking lot.
Okay.
Yeah.
If I see a black dude or Latino dude,
they're in a gang.
If I see a white guy,
he's a serial killer
or a pedophile,
you know?
Right.
Okay.
Yeah.
White guys are either spicy a woman,
she's a whore.
She's a streetwalker.
We're not interested lady about children,
feisty children.
They're a children of the corn.
That's,
yeah,
they just,
they just came out of the milkweeds.
Yeah,
you have,
you have to racially profile,
uh,
at,
at night.
And I think the bigger a pussy you are slashed,
the more vulnerable you are.
Like someone like me never took any martial arts trading.
I just said,
you know,
I got like about 700 fights under my belt all within my,
which is with my brothers,
you know.
So those don't count.
They have to stop at a certain point because they have to answer to your dad.
But like I,
I go out in the parking lot,
you know,
fire him or fought off phone out there in the world.
Uh,
not as much as you,
I'm going to go,
that's the point it was going to make like a woman feels more vulnerable.
Yeah.
Like I don't walk around worried about getting raped.
The only time I have to worry about that is if I go to prison,
you know?
Yeah.
Knock on wood.
So what,
at what time do you start racially profiling when the sun goes down?
So during the winter,
during the winter,
it starts earlier,
like around five.
I was going to say it's awfully early to start racially profiling.
No,
you know what it is.
This is when,
when,
when the second shift comes in,
if you know what I mean.
When the second shift comes in,
that's when I start racially profile.
At the beginning of the day,
people would get up at eight in the morning,
wouldn't,
no matter what color you are,
you get up in the eight in the morning,
you're a good person.
All right.
Your work to the end of the day.
Generally speaking,
you're a good person.
You can get them at eight in the morning.
You're good.
Yeah,
you're a good person unless you're that serial killer who just goes to work
every day and like,
yeah,
but I'm just saying generally speaking or got a fucking piece of shit on Wall
Street or a banker looking,
I,
there's a lot of flaws in my theory.
All right.
But I'm,
I'm talking about,
I'm talking about just like worrying about physical violence.
Okay.
If you get up eight in the morning,
like it's very hard to get your ass kicked between eight and five in the morning
and five in the afternoon.
This is what I'm saying.
But APP wants this,
your kid on the school yard,
there you go.
Exactly.
As an adult.
There you go.
Right.
So,
but after,
once the sun starts going down on the second shift comes out,
you know,
that's when,
uh,
like that,
that's when,
you know,
all of a sudden,
the fucking 28 days,
people come up from the manholes,
you know,
drug dealers come out,
the fiends come out,
depending on where you're at.
That's when,
yes,
that's right.
That's right.
The fucking stockers,
the guys with the date rape drug who honestly puts the date rape drug in
somebodies morning coffee,
you know,
do it.
When was the last time somebody got raped?
When the sun was up?
I am sure people get raped on this.
Sun Is no,
if you get rates on the sun is up,
you're asking for it.
Oh my God.
Yeah.
Well I have to top your,
I don't like this country thing.
I'm trying to bring some of their hate on me.
Okay,
good.
Um,
yeah,
so I'll,
I'll,
I'll admit that I,
I'll admit that to you.
I,
yeah,
I racially profile at night,
but if there's a bigger group of people around and I feel safer than the racial
racial profile profiling goes down.
But seriously,
if I,
you know,
if you're a white guy with the shaved head during the day,
you have cancer at night,
you're part of,
you're part of a fucking Arion group.
Yeah.
I think I would be nervous if I was coming out of somewhere or,
and there was a whole gang of white guys that were like look like they were in a
frat and they were being loud and rowdy.
That would make me really nervous if I was walking and they were chanting rape
is rape,
rape is right dude,
oo do you agar bomber or some shit like that and they're all,
you know,
slapping each other on the back with their Letterman jackets.
That would make me very nervous to see cause because you saw the accused,
right?
I mean what are you basing this on?
I don't know.
I don't like those.
I don't like jockey kind of Frat guys.
Anyway,
this is awesome.
This is such a great podcast.
Okay.
Cause I date.
See everybody.
Yeah.
See that's the thing.
Everybody does it,
which gets me back to this.
Everybody does that shit.
And then when somebody and yeah,
and then when somebody steps out of line,
everybody gets to act like they don't think anything fucked up.
And I'm not saying,
you know that I uh,
that this is something right about like they look there,
there's gray areas where you have to think the worst of people so you can get to
your fucking car,
unlock it,
get in the shit.
Yeah.
I got freaked out the other night when I got in my car.
I just immediately felt like there was someone in the back seat,
like one of those horror movies.
Right.
And then I was also nervous because I had been singing with the radio.
It's like,
great,
this person tends to kill me and they think I'm a nerd.
Probably makes it easier to kill.
Yeah.
I'm going to miss this guy with this thing,
especially with the bucket seats,
it's so easy to reach around and just stab you in the fucking chest.
We're back in the day.
I mean we share the same car again and scare me.
Okay,
well I won't say I won't say that then.
Oh,
by the way,
everybody I've made the decision.
Um,
yeah,
and basically by you guys,
you know,
to like,
listen,
we're,
we,
we both exposed a lot of a ugly parts about itself.
So before you guys fire up any fucking emails trashing my girlfriend or me or
whatever,
look in the fucking mirror.
Okay,
go,
go look,
go look at your cookies before you delete them on the Internet.
Look at the last fucking 17 websites you went to.
So let's,
let me ask you that.
How about that?
That's a great podcast segment.
Let me here and I want to hear from everybody.
Men,
women,
black,
white,
Latino,
Asian.
I want to hear you guys.
I want to hear like some of the times when,
uh,
you know,
you've,
you've done your own little racially profiling or you looked,
or people who aren't white,
how you think,
how you look at some white people.
Cause I think that's really interesting.
Like you don't hear that.
Like it's always white people on TV.
You have to like confess and apologize behind the podium,
like my old bit go and like,
you know,
they had that rap music.
It was loud.
I got nervous.
I didn't realize that they were the swim team and they were just trying to get
amped up.
Didn't you see them in the,
in their little speedos?
I don't know the music,
just blurt everything out.
You know.
So I want to hear from,
I want to hear from basically,
I want to hear from fucking everybody,
but basically times when when you've,
uh,
you've thought shit like that,
um,
or whatever.
I don't know,
just so we can get something positive out of this because so many times somebody
makes a comment like that,
like you made that kind of give a shit about the country's birthday and then
immediately that's,
that's the sound bite they take and then it becomes all it.
Then you actually get into,
oh yeah,
yeah.
Cause your uncle got,
you know,
got the shit kicked out of him because,
uh,
he,
his muffler was dragging as he drove himself to church in the cops felt that
they needed backup.
Exactly.
Yeah.
So,
um,
all right.
Yeah.
Okay.
So let's,
uh,
what was the last,
I just lost my entire train of thought.
You were saying you want people to write in all know ethnicity,
but I was going on,
I was going on.
There was one other fucking thing that happened yesterday.
You said I have decided you've got to speak into the mic.
Oh,
you said the,
I have decided to,
uh,
I get nothing.
Was this about the car?
Oh yes.
No,
the car I want to get.
No.
Yeah,
this is it.
Okay.
My girlfriend's beyond fucking cool.
Right,
right.
Sorry.
There was a little bit of a poor coming up there.
I was like,
you know,
you get like that air bubble just comes up.
My girlfriend's beyond cool.
Um,
I'm gonna get,
I'm gonna get that dodge challenger.
Um,
I'm going to get it.
And I actually,
I was looking at the one down there with the fucking stick shift.
I don't know when I'm getting it,
but I'm getting that car.
I don't give a fuck if I got to get a used one.
But,
and I think it's hilarious because the stick shift one,
you actually have to pay a gas guzzler tax 1300 bucks out here and because it
only takes you,
that's even better.
So I keep the fucking side,
the passenger seat looking cute.
All right missy.
So anyways,
I think it's funny,
like it says it gets 14 miles city,
which means if you actually drive it like a fucking any sort of a man,
you're only getting like nine.
And how much is that going to cost you?
It's a that don't fucking kill my fun.
Alright.
No,
that's going to be,
the car will drive the Prius around like a couple of quiz.
Right.
We'll do that.
And then,
and then it's uh,
the cars,
the shit,
it's a great car.
It's like a great girlfriend.
She's a cheap date.
She doesn't want anything.
And then that'll be the whore that it bring out every Sunday the garage comes
up.
Bubba,
Bubba
[inaudible].
Okay.
That's what I want to do.
Make the tires squeal,
capture the last drop a youth I've had.
I know that,
you know,
cause I actually,
I looked at a bunch of cars I looked at like those use BMWs by can't believe
it's that someone already farted in his car seat.
You when they try to like they're brand new and uh,
I just think everything,
everything looks like a fucking Mercedes or BMW and the,
that dodge challenger,
despite the fact that the Camaro's out there and the Mustang,
it's still is one of the most unique looking bad ass cars out on the road.
And I know it's American,
which means it can go fucking in a straight line.
It's the shit.
But if you take a turn,
unlike those Julep over.
Yeah.
Unlike those German cars,
it's a little excitement with it,
you know?
Yeah.
No,
you don't give a fuck.
You know,
she,
my girl doesn't want me to get the car.
It's so much money.
Yeah,
no,
I get it again.
Well that's why,
you know,
that's why you cool.
Cause any of it.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Get that.
And I'm going to sit down whenever you want.
A new guitar.
I say,
go get it.
You've earned the money to spend on it.
So go get yourself a new guitar.
You and I look that you give that.
Yes.
You're very supportive about giving me the green light to spend my money on
myself.
That's a great thing.
You know what,
this is the long she'd been on the podcast and yeah,
I gotta tell you,
you bring a lot to the podcast.
Okay.
You bring,
you bring jokes,
you bring a bubbly attitude and you bring a little controversy.
You bring a little controversy.
I was really surprised.
But you know,
said I not have said that.
No,
you should have because there's no way anybody shut it off after that.
There's no way anybody's shut it off after that.
And uh,
I think generally speaking,
we'll get good emails,
but there will be a bunch of fucking douche she wants.
I would like to point out that back in the day I really wanted to get one of
those,
uh,
flag Bikini's
Oh.
Dot.
They were awesome.
So like hot and sexy and whatever,
but then you go,
if you really look like a trashy,
especially if you wear it in a different country,
if you buy one of those Nia,
I will learn to ride a fucking motorcycle just so you can be on the back with
your booty crack peeking outing out of the flat.
I saw that.
Like there's no way for a woman to ride on the back of a motorcycle without her
fucking underwear hanging out.
I saw this skinny girl was on the back of a bike yesterday in her entire,
like,
you know the Thong where you have like,
it's not,
it's not a g string,
it's a thong.
So you have that slice of Pie,
bit of fabric is hanging out.
The top of it was where,
where the,
the tramp stamp tattoo should have been by the time she leaned forward.
Yeah,
it was great.
It was America is speaking of which I saw a girl,
a couple,
well I saw her,
this,
this last pool party I went to and she's a great girl,
but she has a,
uh,
made in
the USA Tattoo in the tramp stamp area.
Wow.
It's,
God bless her.
Awful.
She's a great girl.
And I said,
oh,
so are you,
you know,
in the the,
the armed forces or something?
Fuck the whole base.
No,
she was just like,
I just love this country.
When you put the microphone,
there you go.
I love,
I love what this country stands for and I'm really proud to be an American.
And I said,
all right,
you let her get away with that.
I mean,
what was I gonna say?
Okay,
I respect that.
What were you gonna say?
Cause I thought,
no,
I'm just really patriotic.
Yeah,
no,
you're,
you're right.
I just kind of accepted it.
She said she,
I asked her,
she gave me an answer and moved on and now I'm exposing her on the vodcast sorry
,
you were talking about how like,
you know,
cause I'm always looking at cars,
right?
Yeah.
On the Internet and all that type of shit.
And uh,
he was saying,
why do they always have like the women draped over him and all that?
Because the whole thing,
it's that guy visual thing.
You know what I mean?
Like when I,
when I look at the,
I'm not lie to you,
like when I was looking at that challenge or I actually got,
I got a little aroused and I'm not even,
I'm not even joking.
No,
I'm serious.
Remember how you wanted to get off the lot.
But I was sort of lingering with one of my hands in my pocket.
I had filled up a little bit longer.
I know,
but I'm saying like she is tapped into that with that made in the USA thing.
Um,
oh.
Like guys will be into that,
that whole sort of like fuck.
And I got a bear.
I got a fucking car on.
This is my fucking woman.
Yeah.
4th of July.
You got a sparkler.
She's blowing you.
She's a lesbian.
Did she?
Good looking lesbian.
That's where I draw the line.
Oh,
there you go.
Okay.
Yeah.
I have no tolerance for not good looking lesbians.
I'm really a snob when it comes to this power rate.
A lot of lesbians I like,
Oh,
now you just dug the hole again.
Like there's ugly straight people.
There's ugly lesbians.
So what did,
what did I like good looking lesbians and I like what you do because you're a
straight man that has a fantasy of being with like a couple of,
I don't know,
I'll just jerk off in the corner like a gentleman.
I would rather you admit to wanting to have a threesome with lesbians and say
you'll just want to be free if I want to wear a raincoat.
Yeah.
Like I'm in my creepy years,
I'm 42 dark socks pulled up to the knees when tips,
sneakers,
shoes.
I mean,
um,
no I don't,
I don't have like any,
uh,
I,
I don't have any,
I have zero tolerance.
Be attractive as a lesbian step up your game.
I have had it.
Why Mediocre looking glass?
I didn't realize I was such a problem.
There is one group of people in this country.
There you that I think needs to get out.
Take the hit off me.
Maybe they're talking about these illegal immigrants.
As long as you're good looking,
you can come into this fucking country.
I am equal up kick ugly.
We believe.
Yeah.
That's what I get to stay for some reason.
Well,
you're not ugly,
Huh?
Uh,
I'm a very,
very attractive.
Okay.
Please.
What?
Please,
how hard did you laugh the other day when you,
you,
you would put those little fashion fucking slits in your,
in your jeans.
Hmm.
And I was joking that I was going to do it my jeans.
I said,
what would you do if I said that?
And my jeans exposing my creamy thighs.
How hard did you laugh?
I'm a fucking mutiny.
I'm one step away from being a fucking albino.
All right.
We're all like,
we're like an hour to minutes in here.
That very controversial.
Nia Renee Hill.
Everybody look at that took up like an hour your day.
Happy fourth,
everybody forth.
And,
uh,
I'm sorry.
If you had to work today,
I hope this,
uh,
this podcast made it a little more enjoyable.
Uh,
Hey,
can I get a God bless the troops or something from your knees?
Absolutely.
God bless the troops.
100%.
There you go.
There you should go perform for them.
They're doing a lot.
So you want me to go do that Gig on the front lines?
I'm going to fucking do it.
I think you should.
I'm doing that and I'm getting the fucking challenger.
I eat the America.
They don't get nearly as a pre.
I mean everyone says they appreciate the troops,
but I don't know that they get a lot of love,
especially from people who are anti this war,
but they're doing a lot of shit that most people wouldn't do.
So I commend them.
Yeah.
This goes back to my brave,
my bit,
that bit that I was doing what they were saying,
being a mother,
it's the toughest job on the planet.
Really.
Go fight a fucking war lady.
Put your apron and go make a pie.
It's America's birthday.
All right.
Thanks for listening to everybody talk to you.
[inaudible]
[inaudible].